that sharks are just straight-up
man-eaters which they aren't I'm coyote
Peterson I'm a host of the brave
wilderness channel on YouTube oftentimes
the only reason you're attacked by shark
is because a you're in the shark's
environment you're out there swimming in
the ocean and sharks oftentimes mistake
humans for prey so imagine yourself on a
paddleboard or a surfboard from
underneath you look like a sea lion or a
sea turtle
so that shark comes into the environment
and what it's doing it's in it's
investigating right sharks never just
grab onto something and tear it apart
their method for catching their prey is
actually to come in and do a test bite
oftentimes that test bite can be so
lethal it ends up killing the prey and
imagine how soft a human body is the
tiger shark comes up and thinks maybe
you're a sea turtle and takes a bite
swims away you're gonna be in pretty bad
shape so it's often times people die
from shark bites not so much being eaten
by sharks so as long as you're safe in
the environment that you're in you pay
attention to the warnings on the beach
pay attention to the local media if
sharks have been spotted in that area
it's actually rather simple to avoid
sharks if you're paying attention to
your surroundings if you are in the
process of being attacked by shark the
sensory perception organs that they have
in their nose specifically their noses
in their eyes that's how they sense
their environment so being able to hit
an animal on it's not like that can
oftentimes deter them from continuing
the attack so if you're in the position
where you're being attacked by something
like a shark obviously fight with your
life no matter what you can do to make
sure that you can get away
you
you